amc is one of the most fascinating
stocks
in public markets right now amc
has become a meme stock and there's lots
of people who hate it
i think jim chanos today the famed short
seller said he's got a short position on
the business
but amc said yesterday an earnings call
by the end of the year they will be
accepting bitcoin
now here's what's so fascinating about
amc
this business was taken as a darling of
the internet
by the reddit and the meme stock crowd
meme stocks are not new
berkshire hathaway is the ultimate meme
stock
warren buffett is jesus the disciples
of berkshire hathaway go on mecca
every single year to omaha to the
berkshire hathaway annual meeting
there is an entire religion there is an
entire holder base
that looks up to and does whatever
warren buffett wants
berkshire hathaway is a meme stock we
just never had used that terminology to
describe it
amc is a meme stock as well and there
are people around
the country who have diamond hands who
are not selling
and so yesterday during the earnings
call it was expected that they were
gonna have 91
cents loss per share but actually it
came in at only 71 cents
they lost less money than people
expected that's good
they lost less than expected their
revenue was expected to be 382 million
dollars
it came in actually at 445 million
and so they only lost only
561 million dollars in q2 2020
but that was 5.38 cents per share
now they only lost 71 cents big big
improvement obviously the pandemic is
not having as big of an
issue and so it's a 17 billion market
cap business
that now says that they are going to go
ahead and accept bitcoin
this is a genius move
by amc they understand who their
shareholders are
they understand that they have an
opportunity to continue
to get their shareholders involved in
the business continue
to keep the stock price moving continue
to have access to capital markets that
may not have been available to them
otherwise
and so what do those young people care
about they care about bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies
what better way to continue to rally the
troops than to offer
the fact that you can pay in bitcoin do
i expect people to actually
use bitcoin unlikely people want to get
paid in bitcoin pay me in bitcoin not me
pay you in bitcoin
but that's okay the fact that amc is
embracing this and saying
we will accept bitcoin by the end of the
year is another
stroke of genius that says amc
understands where the future is heading
and they plan to be a part of it now
we've got a couple of charts when you
look at this chart
of the market cap of amc prepare
yourself
this is nuts
[Music]
amc was just chilling for years since
before 2015 2014 2013 and then it
exploded in 2021.
it's come down a little bit but it is
still much much higher 17 billion
market cap today than it was in 2020
december 30th of 2020 the market cap
was less than half a billion dollars
today it is 17 billion dollars
absolutely nuts to see this type of
growth over 30 x
increased this year 22 million guests
visited theaters in q2
and employees last year was 25 000 which
was down 35 percent
if you look at the underlying
fundamentals of this business there is
reason for people to say
it may not be worth 17 billion but it
has one of the most important things
which
has a highly engaged shareholder base
who has confidence that the executive
team will turn it around
who knows the market is the ultimate
referee and so what we can see is we've
got another chart that shows the amount
of coverage that amc has received
and then the price movement and what's
fascinating to me is in white
this is the story count on stock twits
and then in blue
is the actual price of amc
you can see that there was a big price
uptick
right in january when there started to
be a couple of stories people talking
about maybe
amc let's go to the movies maybe we
should actually go
and start to participate in the stock
and then it exploded upwards
and it's kind of continued and then in
june there was another explosion upwards
until
the actual price of the stock hit 60 or
so
and now it's come back down we're
sitting around 37 a share
but still much much higher than we
previously were
and so if we continue looking we got two
more charts here
the number of movie theaters that are
operational
by amc you can see that from 2015 to
2016
there was actually a big leap forward
right the
big piece of that leap ended up being
material but since 2016 there has been
no material movement for the most part
in the number of theaters that are being
added
they still operate right around 900 to a
thousand over the last four or five
years
and then if we go and we look at the
seats for us movie tickets
they're not actually off to that fast of
a start so if you look at 2019
and 2021 in july usually there is a
big spike for movie ticket sales but
this july
we didn't see that we are much much
lower than where we were two years ago
and so when we think about this stock
what we have
is we have a shareholder base that
believes in amc they are aping into amc
they have built a community of highly
engaged highly passionate people
some of them are buying it for potential
future returns
some of them are buying it as a middle
finger to the system some of them are
buying it to replace the entertainment
that they got from sports betting or
something else
and some of them are buying it merely
because
they want to see what investing is all
about
regardless of why they're buying it
they're buying it and the ceo and the
board of amc
really really understands this if i
remember correctly the
ceo of amc or the chairman i can't
remember which one i'm pretty sure was
amc
did an interview earlier this year and
he had party up top or i'm sorry he had
business up top
party down low he didn't have pants on
and at one point he dropped the camera
in the interview and you could see that
he just had his underwear on
whether it was intentional or not the
gorillas of amc went
nuts they knew he's speaking to us
and so when that happens what you get is
you get
further engagement with the community
and they started to play into it they
started to offer things to shareholders
if you own a share of stock you get
certain perks at the actual
theater this to me is a genius move to
accept bitcoin do we think anyone's
actually going to pay in bitcoin though
no no i think i think it's going to be
even a bigger move when they start
paying their employees in bitcoin
do you think that that is possible that
that that's the next step after they
accept bitcoin they'll pay people in
bitcoin well it depends on if people pay
bitcoin what do they do with that
bitcoin do they hold it on their balance
sheet or do they transfer it to
cash usd whatever form of currency they
want
i i think they hold it on their balance
sheet pelena
i think it's more of a signal and like a
like a
dog whistle i don't know what that means
but it's like
look at what we stand for versus the
actual
practical like you can buy your tickets
that's what i think is the genius move
right i agree with you and i think that
the genius move here
is when you put a flag in the ground and
say we will accept bitcoin as uh as
payment
what you're saying is we are innovative
we understand the internet we agree with
you like we are in this battle together
even if not one single person pays in
bitcoin we are not
87 years old
but true right like that is what they're
saying they are appealing to a younger
demographic
and as i've said over and over and over
and over again bitcoin is good for
business
whether you buy it and put it on your
balance sheet whether you accept it as a
means of payment or you simply adhere to
the same ethos
bitcoin is good for business and that to
me feels like what amc is doing here now
the question becomes
if they start to accept it and to john's
point somebody does pay them and they
hold it on the balance sheet
what would happen if they went and
ripped off a bitcoin
uh market buy order and put bitcoin on
the balance sheet
it's hard to do because they're losing
money right so they're in they have
weird financial i think they have 1.8
billion in cash
so what if they took 300 million dollars
let's say right and they said you know
what
or let's just say they took 10 percent
took 180 million bucks and they said
we're gonna go buy bitcoin
and we're gonna buy 180 million dollars
worth of bitcoin we're gonna put on our
balance sheet
and then now everyone knows not only are
we gonna accept bitcoin but we have
bitcoin on our balance sheet as amc
and if you want exposure to bitcoin
similar to
buying square or tesla or microstrategy
for the same reasons you potentially
could buy this
if bitcoin's price goes up our stock
should do well
and also as a signal to everyone that we
get the future
that would be the biggest change of
their business in the last 10 years
i think has really changed in their
business in the last five 10 years
amc absolutely should go buy forget 180
million dollars if they got 1.8 billion
dollars of cash on the balance sheet
they literally should go buy in my is my
personal opinion
500 million dollars worth of bitcoin
they should turn around to the market
and say we have young people who care
about this we have young people who know
that this is the future and what we're
going to do is we're basically going to
rally around the shareholder base and
what we're going to do is we're
immediately going to go out we're going
to get more debt we're going to put it
on the company we're going to take the
debt we're going to buy bitcoin
michael saylor strategy on top of that
what they could do is take every single
one of their physical locations
and they could immediately start to do
things around bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies
i although we'll talk later about nfts i
think they can do a whole bunch of stuff
with nfts et cetera the second you start
to go down this path it becomes really
really interesting
i have a hot take uh-oh so listen
you're trying to get joe fired and
you're bringing hot takes all right my
hot take
is tying this topic to the last topic i
think that
basically the politicians who are more
um like
friendly with businesses with the
private sector i think they're gonna see
this happen
and i think they're gonna recognize the
level of engagement
of these like memers of finance and
they're gonna start talking more about
crypto and bitcoin and they're actually
gonna get educated and that's how it
seeps into politics
through business oh i completely agree
with that actually i don't think it's a
hot take at all
right it is the politicians care what
the business people care about the
business people care about what their
customers and their shareholders care
about and it's very obvious that amc is
a great example
young shareholders care about this stuff
and they're obviously going to keep
doing it
uh john do you own amc
no no you're you're you're out on the
meme stocks my
i don't mind the meme stocks i am
gonna need a little negative but like i
don't mind amc as a business makes sense
to me
what what their movie theory goes see
the movies they just
like structure yeah it structurally
makes sense to me gamestop doesn't
really make sense to me
it's a retail video game store so
personally like i'm going to invest
based off the structure of the business
and the revenue
and everything like that i'm not a movie
guy yeah well i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna
basically put my money because of the
hype around it right and some people do
and some people made a lot of
look if i knew that it was gonna go up
like it did i would have put some money
in pulled back out
tried to play a little day trading
action but i didn't
wait wait wait a minute if you were
going to tell me it was going to go to
like 60
a share from five dollars yeah i would
have put money into it
[Laughter]
yeah if you could tell the future yeah
hey guys thanks so much for watching
that clip of the best business show
make sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday
and then head to sofi.com so that you
can get an account
we can get after it
you